so I had been a photographer for 18
years before I began the microscopy
project and in that time I had shot
global ad campaigns I had the
opportunity to photograph some of my
generations icons and I was traveling
the world you know I got to a point in
my career that I dreamed of getting to
and yet for some reason I still felt a
little bit unfulfilled and I despite the
extraordinary things I was shooting and
experiencing they'd started to feel a
little bit ordinary to me and I was also
getting concerned about how disposable
photography had started to feel in the
digital world and I son I really wanted
to produce images that had a sense of
worth again and I needed a subject that
felt extraordinary sometimes I wish I
had the eyes of a child and by that I
mean I wish I could look at the world in
the same way as I did when I was a small
boy I think there's a danger as we get
older that our curiosity becomes
slightly muted or dulled by familiarity
and as a visual created one of one of
the challenges for me is to present the
familiar in a new and engaging way
fortunately for me though I've got two
great kids who are still curious about
the world
sebastien he's still curious about the
world and in 2014 in spring he brought
in a ground beetle from the garden and
there was nothing particularly special
about this insect you know it was a
common species but he was still curious
and he brought it up to my office and we
decided to look at it under his
microscope he had a little science kit
for Christmas and this is what we saw
now when I first saw this it blew me
away you know up here this is the back
of the ground beetle when I first saw it
it reminded me of a galaxy and all the
time this has has been outside our
window you know I was looking for this
extraordinary subject and it's excepts
eyes and curiosity to bring it into me
and so I decided to photograph it for
him and this is what I've just
and I basically asked myself two simple
questions the first one you know could I
take all my knowledge and skill of
photographic lighting and take that onto
a subject that's five millimeters long
but also could I keep creative control
over that lighting on a subject that
size and so I practice some smell of
found specimens and I approached the
Oxford University Museum of Natural
History to see if I could have access to
their collection to progress the product
and I went up there for a meeting and I
showed them some of the images that I'd
been shooting and they could see the
kind of detail I was able to get and I
don't think they'd ever really seen
anything quite like it before and from
that point forward they gave me open
access to their entire collection and
the assistance of dr. James Hogan their
entomologist now over the next two and a
half years
I shot 37 insects from their collection
and the way I work is that I essentially
split the insect up into multiple
sections and I treat each one of those
sections like a spawn still life so for
example if I was photographing the eye
of an insect which is you're normally
quite smooth and dome-shaped then I'd
use a light source there is large and
soft diffuse so I don't get any harsh
hot spots on that surface but once my
attention turns over to a hairy leg that
lighting setup will change completely
and so I make that one tiny section look
as beautiful as I possibly can and I'll
work my way across the insect until I
have about 20 or 25 different sections
the issue with photography at high
magnification is there is inherently a
very shallow depth of field so to get
around that what I do is I put my camera
on a rail that I can automate to move 10
microns in between each shot
that's about 1/7 the width of a human
hair and then that provides me with the
stack of images deep stack of images
each has a tiny sliver of focus all the
way through and I can squash that down
to produce one image that is fully
focused from front to back and so
essentially there gives me 25 sections
that fully focused and beautifully lit
now each one of my images is made up of
anywhere between eight and ten thousand
separate shots they take about three and
a half weeks to create and the file size
is on average or about four gigabytes so
I've got plenty of information to play
with when I'm printing and the prints at
the exhibition around the three meter
mark in fact I had a show in Milan two
weeks ago and we had some prints there
that were nine meters long but you know
I realize that these images they're
still out of work in the digital world
you know it's no point in me putting on
my blood sweat and tears into these
pictures if they're any clearly shown
500 pixels on a screen so with the help
of Rob Chandler and we'll Cookson we
developed a website that enables the
viewer to immerse themselves in to the
full four gigabyte files and they can
explore all that microscopic detail and
so if you have time and I encourage you
please visit micro sculpture net and go
and have a play it's good from so I
first showed the work at Oxford and
since then it's moved on to the Middle
East is now back in Europe and goes to
Copenhagen this month and the feedback
is has been great you know I get email
was actually all over the world from
teachers at the moment who are used in
the website in school kids are using
them on the tablet they're zooming into
the pictures and drew using it for art
class biology class and that's not
something I planned that's just a
beautiful offshoot of the project in
fact one of the things I like to do with
the exhibitions it's actually look at
the kiddies reactions and they could
have you know standing in front of a
three meter insect they could have been
horrified but they don't they look in
wonder this little chap here he stood
there for 5 minutes motionless
and at the end of the day actually at
the end of the day of the exhibitions we
have to wipe down the lower third of the
big prints just remove all those sticky
hand prints cuz all they want to do is
touch those big bugs
now I'd want to leave you with one final
image of that's okay and this is do with
Charles Darwin now one of the recent
images that I photographed was this one
here oh and I'm talking about the
creature in the box not my cat and this
is a shield bug that Charles Darwin
brought back from Australia on the HMS
Beagle in 1836 and when I got it home I
stood in my kitchen and stared at it for
about 20 minutes but I couldn't believe
that I was in possession of this
beautiful creature and at that moment
our cuts kind of realized that this
validated the project for me the fact
that the museum were willing to risk me
playing with this kind of showed me that
my images had worth you know they
weren't disposed one and that's the
image that I produced and I often wonder
you know still when I look at this what
would Charles Darwin make of these
images now do you think you'd like his
picture of his shield bug and I hope so
so
yeah I think it's strange in a way I'm a
visual person I'm a creative person but
I still needed the eyes of a child to
find my extraordinary subject that's the
way it was it's all I can say is thank
you very much Sebastian now I am very
very grateful thank you
[Applause]
[Music]